[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un d'une petite fille
qui qu'avec un monstre est en fait ces
parents croient pas et puis en fait un
peu trop bien ses parents qu'il existe
moi je pense personnellement toutes les
bêtises que fait le petit garçon est dit
que c'est un monstre qui l'inventé lui
même et puis comme ça ils évitent de se
réunir pour ce banc il dort avec elle
jouit où sa mère qui n'a plu et m'a cité
que youtube et sur une hausse à la volée
la constructeur dès sa maman un
sèche-cheveux bruce lee les grands
ennemis pour mieux entrer double
attachés
c'est beaucoup plus petit mais petit
garçon il était de 6,8 jusqu'à 100
les monstres du plaqueur ne devait pas
se brosser les dents le matin j'ai l'air
de poids - avec une pince à linge sur le
nez il va moi je pense qu'en fait le mot
source l enfant qu est ce que tu
aimerais vraiment bas ça pourrait être
marrant et ouais oui je trouve que cette
pratique est appelé la tribu qui pue
parle de nos tribunes orphelins et ils
ont appris à se débrouiller tout seul
c'est un peu trouillard
il ya là la directrice de l'orphelinat
le village était bien essayé de les
capturer elle attend bien et
heureusement leur chef arrive à les
sauver alami des cailloux et puis bien
commun l'ami de cailloux et ben ça ça
bloquer la machine et il faut en procès
[Musique]
il est transformé la lutte
et vont rentrer dans la tribu ce que je
la main ils vont rester avec eux pour
est simple quand même c'était un peu le
jeu vient lire une histoire aux autres
qu'ils sont c'était amusant ce qui est
des fois il disait des trucs rigolos
[Musique]